hello youtuber verse coming up a new
episode of star talk cosmic queries
edition this time neuroscience this is
Startalk I'm your host Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist and
this episode of star talk a cosmic
queries edition is focusing on
neuroscience and we go to our go-to
person for that and that would be the
none other than Heather Berlin Heather
welcome back to Startalk for the
millionth time thanks I love always love
being here Nowell excellent thank you
thank you and you you're a
neuroscientist at Mount Sinai is it
correct the way to say that and you
focus on what people are thinking when
they don't know they're thinking but no
I studied brains and how they relate to
human thoughts behaviors whether they're
conscious or unconscious okay that's
scary actually we have a first-timer
here my co-host Jackie Hoffman Jackie
welcome thank you knew your comedian I
am an actress slash comedian in that
order
well yes okay right now doing more
acting than comedian okay and I had a
hysterectomy at Mount Sinai Oh
congratulations
is that a TMI I hope they did a good job
it's awareness week okay so let me join
you in that and say I was born in Mount
Sinai yes both my children were born in
outside ok but I never had a
hysterectomy you never know so Jackie
you said you also an actress you were
you had a role in in Legally Blonde -
yes Neal remembered my joke my line was
it was one lot your dogs are gay change
the world I would give you more lines
than that if I were if I were producer
of Legally Blonde - thank you okay so
also you are in a all Yiddish production
of fiddler on the roof off
right now that is correct that's crazy
with English subtitles don't panic okay
Yiddish has got to be like that's how it
would have been they would have been
speaking Yiddish that is correcting an
advancing Yiddish and you your character
is into the match so basically you're
playing my grandmother yeah very cool so
since this is cosmic queries we
solicited from our fan base questions
for this episode on neuroscience grant
Ann what a topic that has become Heather
there's a word no one knew 20 years ago
and now everybody's into it so I mean I
knew about it I mean nobody else knew
right so Jackie you have the questions I
haven't seen them neither has Heather
and these are questions that bring it on
let's see what we've got okay our first
comes from John Emerson from Pat rayon I
don't know what that patreon that's our
that they're a support website that
helps fund our operation oh nice I
thought it was a tequila so that's why
you're reading their question first I
see one of the perks of the many perks
you get support the patrons at patreon
patreon patreon thank you okay I've
heard that men are from Mars and women
are from Venus with it a little bit
involves you know from Mars and women
are from Venus but are there any
neurological differences between these
two planetary species yeah a question
for you into the matchmaker it's
actually it's you know it's been
controversial in the past because often
it's not been PC to say that there are
differences between men and women's
brains but there are there are they're
both sort of anatomical differences
neural chemical differences hormones
that affect brain chemistry like
oxytocin things like test testosterone
and estrogen affect how the brain works
so we know that for example on average
and these are all again on average women
have slightly larger hippocampus is the
part of the brain that has to do with
memory they tend to store emotional
memories better than men they tend to
ruminate on things
a little bit more than men as we might
know anecdotally and in terms of like
the way their brains are wired up it
slightly different female female yeah
language which tends to be lateralized
meaning that it's more on localized on
the left side lateral eyes would mean
it's featured more for anything with
meat more on one side than the other
exactly I realize lateral eyes so it
tends to be more lateralized than men
meaning that more of their languages
just on the left side whereas women tend
to have language on both in both
hemispheres like parts of the brain that
are dedicated to language processing
they tend to use more words just in
behaviorally during the day than men so
there are certain aspects of women's
brain both anatomically and and
physiologically that differ from men and
they express themselves in different
ways behaviorally emotionally in terms
of cognition so has this gotten
resistance from society even have that
conversation there's some you know
because then the idea is like well you
know well then there's this this myth
like okay well if a bigger brain must be
better men on average have a physically
larger brain but that's not true in
terms of intelligence in terms of
cognitive function it's about how its
wired up it's not about the size so but
people did get scared away from this
because the idea like you know famously
I think it was Larry Summers at Harvard
who suddenly or you know a president of
Harvard yes exactly you know women on
you know don't tend to not be do as well
in like math and and tech and that kind
of thing and those things are just not
true they tend to work in different ways
but they're not there's no differences
in terms of men intelligence and
correlated to brain size and the rest so
I think it's ok to say there are
differences and it's neither good or bad
it's just different so I thought his
argument was the averages are all the
same but men show up wider on the
distribution so if you try to find the
highest performing man it's comes way
out on the high performing side you also
have a much lower right hand on the
other side lower than you find the
lowest woman they tend to be more on the
extremes right right
but again that's you know on average so
that means that there are women who are
at these extremes as well on average
tend to be more at the men more at the
extremes in terms of that bell curve of
of IQ
but if you look at it over already yeah
right I mean yeah yeah it's isn't the
shortest person ever a man is that true
Thompson I thought oh yeah but I don't
know if that means that average yeah
yeah I mean that's very you know an N of
one but um women tend to live longer
than men so in that sense we are at the
extreme also look at look at a
personality like for example charisma
right there's some very charismatic men
out there and at the other extreme you
have completely complete sociopaths
right men men are do the most heinous
social things ever right so yeah so
again we have these extremes that the
men or they were populating right or
they just might express them in
different ways like one idea just to go
off a little bit on a tangent but people
who are sociopaths men mostly more
diagnosed in men have these kinds of
impulsive behaviors or they act out
aggressively on others and then they're
categorized as that but women also can
tend to have those extreme behaviors but
they more likely to be introverted and
acted out on themselves like self
harming behavior so there are similar
expressions of like let's say impulsive
behavior but they're expressed different
ways and then they get categorized into
doing I'm disorder so jackieo you from
Mars or Venus which were you Saturn got
me to thank you excellent put a ring on
it
Jackie got another question yes I do
here's one close to my heart from
herbivores on Instagram how does
psychedelics work and what is the effect
on the brain and for personal reasons
I'd like to extend that question to
marijuana as well okay but did you just
add that to the question I did am i
you're you you control the questions you
if you want to slap into shut up so I
mean that's a pretty broad question
there there there is a whole variety of
different types of psychedelic drugs and
they all affect the brain in different
ways so it's not about this is go LSD
let's just go LSD Queen nice yeah okay
so what LSD does on in general is that
it lowers activation in certain parts of
the frontal lobe which have to do with
kind of you have sensory information
coming in and the frontal lobe is kind
of making meaning out of that
information so that it makes sense of it
all when you have decreased activation
in that part of the brain the kind of
meaning make or part of the brain you're
having a whole bunch of sensory
information coming in without a filter
let's say so it's being an experience in
a different way you also have increased
activation in the limbic areas of the
brain these subcortical areas of the
brain so more information is coming from
within it's not being sort of organized
in our in a logical way limbic is that
relational reptilian brain exactly and
the other thing so it is almost like
being in a dream state because during
dreams we see a similar pattern of
activation right you have decreased
prefrontal cortex increase limbic so
you're having emotions and thoughts that
don't necessarily make sense that don't
have a clear narrative but you're also
getting this this the sensory
information that's unfiltered and the
other thing that's really interesting is
that when you look at the way the brain
is kind of sending information back and
forth usually it's in a very kind of you
have certain pathways that the brain
sends information but when they're in
and when they're on LSD there's much
more distributed network of information
so it's kind of like you'd see these a
lot of straight lines and paths and now
they're crossing larger distances within
the brain the information so it's just a
whole different pattern of activation
mmm okay so that makes you feel weird
and trippy yeah well when we have time
later I'll ask you about my
prescriptions you're on right now that's
what we want to know I think that's the
most interesting is that we all are kind
of loosening all the time right because
our brain is making up a story based on
these like signals that are coming in
and then we often say that we all agree
upon it we call it reality yes yes yes
this is it fascinating an important
point because if you have your own
understanding of reality and no one else
can corroborate it right that's just we
declare that it's going on in your head
we don't declare that you have some
special insight into a reality that none
of the rest of us have right is that
fair to say
that's from the brain person's
perspective we all are making up our
reality in our mind but again if nobody
else is agreeing on what you're
experiencing then it's like
just being generated internally and
scientifically we have to assume that
otherwise what you know what are we
based around what are we basing our yeah
we are tree falls in a forest and nobody
hears you asked about the marijuana done
with this so what do you say to people
who would argue that when their brain
has been altered by what ever peyote
artificial chemicals ayahuasca whatever
hmm that they're claiming insight right
into the into the universe mm-hmm what
do you say to them I've had these
discussions with people so they let's
say they claim they say they see a
spirit God and they get insight into the
workings of the universe I think it's
important to understand that we are our
brains are a physical mechanism and a
lot of things just like dream states are
it's creating its own internal world and
so often when we're in a fully awake non
psychedelic state where there's a
certain part of our brain that tells us
whether information is being internally
generated or or coming from external
media and when you're people with
schizophrenia for example they don't
have that proper check in place so they
think they're hearing voices that are
coming externally in because they're not
their brain isn't telling them no it's
you internally being generated so when
you're on these drugs it's similar like
when to a schizophrenic things are being
generated internally from your mind but
you're misinterpreting them as coming
from someplace else like from a spirit
God or somewhere else and that or maybe
you're getting some great insight that's
coming from somewhere so the people
talking to themselves on the street and
who are not on a cell phone they're
really talking to themselves talking to
some other entity but they are
imaginative but they experience it as if
it's another entity yeah but I mean look
this is not to say that there isn't some
great unit you know answer that's coming
through in different ways but it is
curious that well people's who get these
messages when they're on in the
psychedelic states are usually related
to their underlying personal or
religious belief systems that they have
a placer and folds in together with it
yeah yes which makes me which Lee
you to believe that it's internally
generated not externally very good data
on that thank you very much Jack what
you got next well I've got this real
trippy one from Kevin colicky maka on
Instagram okay is everything we
experienced a figment of our imagination
pretty much yeah yeah that's pretty much
that's pretty much I mean I wouldn't say
everything we experienced a figment of
our imagination oh no imagination the
way I experience it is created by my
brain imagine it actually I'd have to
say no because imagination is yes or no
come on have you heaven what do you
think the movie The Matrix yes
everything is happening inside their
brains yes their sense of pain and joy
and love and hate and hunger and all of
that is inside the brain yes okay you
got it so everything you experience is
pain every sensation you have is
happening inside of your brain right yes
but therefore to the question hmm is so
though the answer to that is yes
everything is a brain experience in your
life and and you couldn't have had a
plausible plot in the movie The Matrix
unless that was true yeah but when you
say when when this is the
differentiation I'm making imagination
in the sense of not correlating to
something that's external to your brain
so you can you have a creation of an
experience in your brain of what you're
perceiving that could either be created
internally which I would call
imagination or that's coming externally
from your senses in and so yes they're
both creations of your brain but one is
based on external data on the other
commending externality is where we all
rally around to say that's the reality
yeah but but but the truth be told we
could create a whole sort of matrix
world's just based on sensory inputs
instead of the movie
Total Recall mmm you want to go into you
you want to go on a vacation to alcohol
Cove
you sit in this chair and I will implant
the memories of it in you and now you
wake up you say wow I had a good time I
mean it is just as good it could give
you
we are better blur the light or better
we're probably better know how to do it
because you can skip all the boring
parts like the taxi ride waiting for
your luggage exactly
I got fast forwarding mm-hmm
[Laughter]
time for one more for this segment what
do you have Jackie oh that's a tough
choice but I think I've got one Brian
site on Instagram if sight is the
process of the brain creating an image
of reality after it interprets the
signal from the I sent when they
interact with the electromagnetic field
can a blind person create an image based
on the signal sent from the other senses
to the brain in other words can a blind
person see something yeah yeah so it
depends on okay so our brain something
what that's a really good question so I
waited yeah I want to wait till after
the break let's do the answer to that
question cliffhanger and since the word
electromagnetic was mentioned in there
oh I would just say that's the word we
use to describe the entire spectrum of
light not only the visible light ROYGBIV
red orange yellow green blue indigo
violet but the infrared ultraviolet
x-rays gamma rays microwaves radio waves
all of that is the electromagnetic
spectrum only a tiny slice of it we sent
him to with our eyes so what's
interesting is we have this mechanism
called our eyeballs that takes that and
turns it into an image and it's all
neurological at that level well once you
once your people get good at
neurological stimulus I don't see why
you can't take any external stimulus and
turn it into an image in a brain even if
someone who is blind when we come back
on Startalk we're gonna find out how can
the blind see Heather has the answer to
where we return
back on Startalk cosmic queries
neuroscience edition and we had went to
our go to neuroscience person Heather
Berlin Heather very nice
I got Jackie Hoffman a first-timer as my
co-host puts you tweet at Jackie Hoffman
16 I do what is the sixteen I don't know
my manager picked it because there was
another Jackie Hoffman
that's your query cosmic and cosmic with
a case that's the lamest answer I've
ever heard it's the true never Heather
your time honored the lamest answer ever
on this show Heather you tweet at
Heather Berlin Heather underscore the
same reason like the underscore so
because you have to keep changing your
keyboard sometimes you can't see it I
prefer the - yeah little bit too late
but you could've told me that before so
we let you last left off with a question
about can you I'm going to slightly
rephrase the question knowing that we
have multiple senses into the brain can
you take one sense and turn it into
another - possibly grant the sense of
sight back to a blind person okay but
maybe the sense of smell or touch it and
isn't there this brain we call it a
disorder called synesthesia yeah did
that relate to this answer there's a lot
here so let me just say that it depends
on when the blindness occurred so when
you're born it's in in many ways it's
the gray matter it's like a blank slate
and then it starts to differentiate
based on the inputs it's getting so the
visual cortex in your brain gets inputs
from the retina via the optic nerve
sends information and then over time it
keeps getting inundated with that visual
information so it starts to become the
visual cortex where your experience
visual imagery now their experiments
let's say with with weasels where they
take them early on and they redirect
that visual information to the audit -
what's normally in the auditory cortex
and over time they start to see with
their auditory cortex okay so you can't
depending on how you change the inputs
to the brain you can you can kind of
change what sensory process so there's a
malleability if it happens or early
right now now if you take an adult blind
person who's already kind of formed
their sensory parts of their brain what
you might experience is that if they
were born blind and now they're an adult
they have what we do see in people is
that they have a more well-developed
auditory cortex because they're getting
much more auditory input we're relying
on it they're relying on it more there
and make it kind of recruits other parts
of the brain and some can sort of have a
weird sense of seeing via sound so they
experience it in different ways
and the other the other part of this is
that you there are there is there are
programs now the neural implants where
you can actually they can get
information from the real world like
through a camera directly you implant it
directly into the visual cortex and
it'll stimulate the visual cortex as if
it's information coming from the eyes
and people can begin to sort of start to
see strange sort of images not like
seeing the way you and I do but exactly
and as you perfect this on technology
over time we might be able to really
stimulate the parts of the visual cortex
so the person can see we already do that
now auditorially with the ocular device
yes a nasa invention I might add ah yes
yes and there's a famous talk show host
who got the NASA they got that NASA
implant and it's a Rush Limbaugh he was
going down I only learned this recently
he went like almost completely deaf and
then he got the operation which so it's
it actually here's for you and trans and
and and converts external sound waves
into impulses that your your ear canal
would have otherwise done yeah and I
don't think you hear the sound as you
normally would but you can't hear
differences and sounds that you retrain
to learn what a word is when you hear
those impulses okay say one thing about
synesthesia culture so synesthesia is
where people sort of have a crossing of
sensory areas in the brain so for
example they'll they'll see colors in
sounds or something they'll they'll hear
things in
in written text it's it's a very and so
this one study was really interesting
where they found that certain people
always saw like letters at certain
colors like an a they'd be like a is
obviously red she is blue
C is green whatever it was and what they
did is he did a large study across all
these thinnest seeds who had that
participated eats yes there's a whole
community of synesthetes and they all
they did a survey and they all saw a as
red and B as blue and it was a strange
sort of coincidence we thought and then
they all happen to be born around the
same time when this particular
fisher-price you know those magnets that
you would put on the like refrigerator
letters and numbers yeah and their
synesthesia directly correlated with
that fisher-price set that came out when
they were kids so basically when their
brain was in the early stages of
development and they were exposed to it
they learned an association between
those colors and letters which remains
into adulthood so had to do with a cross
wiring in the brain yeah I mean that's
why I associate every letter with food
because they were no Pete I have M Leo
Pia in my right eye so what I understand
is now my brain is not telling my eye to
look at things it sits there like a
useless Hulk and my whole life is on my
left side I have no vision out of the
right eye when I cover the left eye it
can look at things but my brain is not
talking to it
oh it what you were born with I was born
with it and amblyopia amblyopia I just
called myself an amblyopia just to keep
everybody tweet at you who's an am Leo P
you can be all build a community but no
I think that so basically it's
interesting you can only see out of it
when you cover the other eye is that
correct but you probably can it probably
is getting visual information in the
other eyes dominant yes doctor said if
God forbid anything happens to the good
eye the bad eye will grow on exactly
exactly it's almost like it's it's
basically like an lazy eye that it
because the other eyes so dominant you
kind of over time don't utilize the
information
coming from that I and the other one
becomes stronger the other one becomes
weaker and so yeah child they covered it
with patches the good I to try to strand
right let's I just kept walking into
furniture displaying a lot we can talk
about head injury in the next segment
next what do you have okay from Serena
Rock our on Instagram what will it take
to bring mental health awareness into
the mainstream why is it still such a
stigma what is it about intelligence in
unconventional ways that makes it so
taboo understand the second half of that
year I think that's probably more of a
like why some people say that people
with mental illness are just intelligent
in different ways I think that's
probably related to that tell me about
the history of mental the stigma of
mental yeah mystery of that because it's
sort of a invisible disorder in the
sense like if you break an arm it's very
clear it's a physical problem or you
know you're the heart is having problems
that you can look at the physicality and
the brain is so complex and there's so
much going on in terms of neuro
chemicals and neurophysiology that when
things go wrong in the brain their
hearts I'll just look at and see
physically and they express themselves
and these sort of subjective states a
person you never can really tell if
they're depressed they tell you I feel
depressed angry scale 210 what are you
exactly exactly and so it's all
subjective and because of that
subjectivity people have questioned the
validity of it
because you can't take a microscope and
see it so now as a cognitive
neuroscientist who works in psychiatry
part of what we do is to say look these
psychiatric illnesses this is the
underlying brain dysfunction and we need
to get away from this stigma like it's
all just in your mind like it's not a
real physical thing and so you know the
brain is a physical organ just like you
would fix a bone with a cast if the
brain is is probably improperly working
you can take this particular medication
that's gonna say affects your serotonin
receptors it's just another physical
problem but because it expresses itself
in the subjective way there's a stigma
behind it so I think we're starting to
get away from that I would think so too
yeah you don't I base that on how
candidly people just say oh yeah my
therapist told me the other day
growing up you would never tell anyone
that you had a therapist for any reason
yeah it's just people just just out with
it yeah people are you just meet right
and so for me that's an one measure of
an acceptance factor yeah going on it's
a manifests itself in embarrassing ways
to mental illness you know someone on
the streaking jock yeah right I do that
for a living market people that's what
you do you know I think that creates
such a stigma and it's frightening it's
frightening that could be me and it's
right it's just what what is that
you can't predict the next moment of
their behavior people use those extreme
cases you know like I worked with
psychiatric patients in the in the ER at
Bellevue at one point and these were
really severe these are people you know
those are the ones you pull off the
street and you bring them in the psyche
are and they're really out there you
strap them down and or you give them
something to calm them down or you know
and and so people look at those extremes
and say wait am i the same as that you
know like paranoid schizophrenic and you
know to be honest I've worked with
paranoid schizophrenics were not at that
extreme who are really like nice decent
people and they're just happened to be
having these you know strange delusions
and we can change it with drugs which is
amazing you can give them a drug and
they no longer have these sort of
critter chemistry yeah drugs but I think
you know if it's broken you have to find
ways to fix it excellent yeah Jackie
what else you got for us okay loving
this Monica Stewart from Facebook I had
a brain tumor a meningioma the size of a
baseball removed through a craniotomy
last year how could it get so big before
affecting my motor function speech
memory etc what do we know about brain
tumors in general y'all are my heroes
sending love from Texas in the house
that's a good question so Heather your
thoughts in Texas they grow their tumors
bigger baseball-sized tumor so it's not
just in the brain tumors and other parts
of people's body they don't even know
yeah so they go out of it and then it's
always analogized to a fruit or an
athletic right so what's going on there
well this is it depends on where the
tumor is minute what did she say she had
a meningioma yes so that grows in the
meninges of the brain which is basically
guess that ninjas are basically like
this sort of membrane covers around the
brain and you can get these growths
so it's not directly in the sort of
brain tissue but what happens is it can
get really big and the promise it starts
putting pressure on the brain so
depending on where it's located if it
was located right next to where like
let's say the language area was and it
started pressing and pressure you might
start having problems with your language
so depending it could be in an area
where it's relatively benign and that
you won't get these immediate on
problems or memory problems because
those are something you're saying
putting pressure on an important part of
her I mean they're all important did she
just say that last verb all part of the
brain is listening with my eyes which
one yeah so it depends on where it is
that it will express itself in ways that
are obvious to you like it might express
itself in other ways and it might be
that you know the pressure over time
you'll start having other symptoms like
headaches or but not necessarily the
ones like motor problems but the
different types of tumors are there some
tumors like glioblastoma which is very
deadly which is growing inside the brain
tissue and it's in the top last part of
the brain but that's more insidious and
it gets in kind of the nooks and
crannies and actual cortex and that's
when we go in to remove it you can never
really get all because I used tiny
little tentacles that get in so they
always grow back they grow back and
that's why people don't usually tend to
live longer than a year after that so
and with the meningioma isn't like 90%
of them are benign which is also good so
you can remove it and it usually won't
grow back but yeah they're so they're a
whole variety of different tumors and
have different effects very cool and
kind of ideal II want one to have enough
to affect you at the smallest stage it
can so that you can get to it sooner
yeah that's the whole thing it's a thing
yeah yeah because so it may be a smaller
tumor would have given her motor motor
problems or speech problems if
something's wrong oh the tumor is a golf
ball rather than a big
sometimes they don't even go in and room
if it's like benign they might wait a
while to go in and remove it anyway even
when they find because there's some risk
with surgery and depending on where it's
located there's risk opening up your
skull and poking around your brain my
uterine one was 22 centimeters by the
way oh wow why does the brain oh this is
from and that's the end of my story on
Instagram why does the brain create
images in the form of dreams when we
sleep do dreams have meaning or function
or they just a random collection of
images what are the physiological
advantages of dreaming thank you from
Niki hush Ricky good question hmm
do that fast or okay or give me part of
the answer and then we save the rest of
the answer fruit about this okay let me
give you the shorter answer you get the
one I'm gonna give ya oh you're gonna
give the shorter answer no no let me
give a short version of that question we
can answer that before the break and
then you give me the give the the long
answer long it took a longer question
okay so people want to believe that
their dreams give them insight into some
future events the dreamers they they my
sense of that is the answer is no but
people feel like they have access to the
future through their dreams why after
the break okay we're gonna take our
break and when we come back we continue
with our special edition of cosmic
queries neuroscience edition Startalk
we're back
neuroscience our go-to person Heather
brilliant
person now I like to and Jackie Hoffman
comedian extraordinaire you go away from
person so we left off someone asked
about dreams about dreams and all I can
think of as a Sigmund Freud's book on
the interpretation of dreams where we
come since then yeah so I think Freud
was right in certain things and not in
others he was he was certainly on point
with his whole theories of repression
and dissociation and suppression
I think his internal subconscious well
yeah of course it eco super-ego
conscious that whole that was good the
whole theory of consciousness and
unconscious processes however his whole
interpretation of Dreams was kind of
fringing I tried reading it it was like
this is all [ __ ] yeah it is it is
I'm sorry guys but um so but there's a
lot of theories about why we dream I
mean the the shortest answer is that
it's it's random neural firing and you
only dream during REM sleep by the way
so when your brain is in a certain we go
through different stages rapid eye
movement exactly yeah rock group yeah
okay no I didn't know that I didn't know
their different stages of sleep like
deep sleep and then you know your brain
goes but when it's in the sort of this
dream state it's almost like a waking
state and so your brain in a way is
conscious of what's going on it not
always sometimes you dream you don't
remember your dreams right but usually
you're dreaming in that state and it's
random firing at the brain doesn't make
sense
really if you dreamed and don't remember
you dreamed then how do you know you
dreamed well you can look at a tree is
this the tree question but you don't
remember those you know you dream well
you don't know but we assumed that your
electrodes again that yeah they're
dreaming
there's an interesting justice I know
there's skews of people who like don't
remember things they only have a
shortened memory and so they just feel
like they're just waking up and being
conscious for the first time every
minute because they keep like refreshing
refreshing refreshing so but I mean you
could have a conscious experience and
not remember it but it's still you had
that experience in the moment but the
point is that these dreams don't a lot
of it
cleaning out so you takin a lot of
information a lot of simulation during
the day and the brain has to decide
what's important enough to reinstate to
keep and to reinforce and to kind of
throw away or reinforce it's a word yeah
I don't know that I make it up I might
have made instant or just instantiate
you instantiate the first time thank you
very much thank you it's a roll so what
it does is it reinforces the important
information and consolidates that's a
better word it consolidates the
information and then it gets rid of
other stuff that's sort of junky and so
in that whole process your brain is
firing there's neurons firing and
there's if you're in one of those brain
states during sleep where you're sort of
conscious that information is gonna
manifest itself in a kind of a dream
state it's gonna be based on things
you've been exposed to in your life it's
gonna be based on memories things that
your brain has information of rain has
taken in over the course of your life or
over the course of the day so you'll
place meaning on it when you wake up
you'll try to make sense of it because
that's when the prefrontal cortex is
re-engaged remember the meaning maker
part of the brain but in the actual
dream it's more like a flow State or
like what we see in people who are in
flow States or meditative States or
psychedelic drugs so I hope that answers
the question there's a lot I mean you
could have a whole series on okay so
posed there people who don't dream or
don't remember any of the dreams are
they less mentally with it to remember a
bad - it didn't even matter what one
theory is that it's a threat rehearsal
so that you can actually work out things
in your dream states that help you in
real life for survival yes for survival
so there is some aspect of it that might
be important to help people for survival
in the sense that it's a good thing so
people have recurring dreams right right
and that meant be wit and then Freud
might have it right there where there's
some issues that are being suppressed
that they might want to work out in
there is it false that we do dream every
night we just don't always remember it
or I mean the theory is that we dream
every night again it's very hard to
prove but we don't we don't always
remember it and there is some validity I
don't want to like throw before it
completely under the bus that when you
have in the waking state certain
suppressed memories and thoughts that
when the prefrontal cortex is on it can
keep things that they like emotions and
memories
and when it's released releasing that
inhibition you can those things can come
to the surface thing come out and dreams
like things that you normally are not
aware of in your waking state so it is a
way to access the unconscious but not to
like predict the future I have active
nightmares constantly really like
anxiety dreams that actors have and it's
a real thing like you're on stage your
underlying line you know while you're
there you don't know what you're in my
last one was I sang something wrong and
the composer and lyricist were writing
my one good eye line mm-hmm so that's
just your normal like your anxieties and
fears manifesting a dream in color but
not from right to left just joining us
Jackie is Yenta and Fiddler on the Roof
in an all Yiddish version with English
subtitles
don't panic all right give me another
one
okay here's a quickie this is good from
Ari
subrahmanyam on Instagram do you need a
brain to feel pain as we know it the
jellyfish for instance feel pain I like
that so you don't need more lobster cuz
they scream when you put them on the
oven you know that actually it's illegal
now in the EU to cook lobsters alive
because we claim them they're their
conscious there's enough evidence at the
experience pain and that they have
consciousness so you don't put him in
the boiling water
you kill them some other worse yeah and
then you can more passionate what thank
you also octopus I think that's what it
is as well you can't you can't also kill
an octopus in a way that because we know
that they're very smart very conscious
so is there a neurological primitivity
where you would say they're not really
feeling this pain okay so so the answer
is you don't need a brain you do need
some sort of nervous system all right
nervous system without or without a
brain and so like a jellyfish has that
in its tentacles there's that kind of
has like a neural net and so if you give
it some noxious stimuli or you like poke
its tentacle it will move away it will
retract or if it's really pain yeah I
mean you know as we were say you know I
know
move away from pain right so it's about
like that's how we kind of have to
measure it behaviorally because even
with a human you know the pain again
it's the subjectivity when you go to the
hospital you you know something's wrong
they say okay on a scale of one to ten
how painful is it now they have a smiley
face but yeah so we don't know but we
can tell okay look you retract as if
you're feeling pain so I was at a whole
meeting where we were talking about
animal consciousness and how low down
the sort of food chain does it go and we
had a whole discussion about fish and
fish can they feel and the answer is yes
I mean they again they have a noxious
stimuli they'll retract from it they
have the recorded memories or the old
void that stimuli again so it's as if
they're experiencing something so how do
they kill the lobster before you cook it
I don't know injection by the way by the
way we had on Startalk I interviewed the
founder of PETA Oh and many people
associate PETA with just being you know
all veggie no killing of animals to hear
her speak the philosophy was very
different it was not that she's against
killing animals she's against the
infliction of pain on animals mm-hmm
and I said well what about lobsters she
said she has people working on some kind
of a nest the sizing first pass at the
lobster before you then put it in the
boiling water
yeah has to show you the purity of that
mission statement that it's and so I bet
you if there was a package of that sold
next two lobsters people would buy it of
course yeah of course I think people
would do that if you if you're rich
enough to buy the lobster you got enough
money to buy the lobster anesthetize er
yes before you cook it and just wait
minor correction I think it's the ELA
illegalities in the EU is of for octopus
or octopi never know octopus octopus not
lobsters I just remember that in the
recesses of my mind so you can still
horribly damaged a lobster when you boil
it a lot however the I think that the
real issue is about how animals are
treated and if they are killed in a way
that doesn't cause them drama or sort
trauma or stress
drama we don't want drama drama queen or
like you know temple grant we have an
actor here yeah my girl my bit of drama
mm-hmm I know it's lame but I still do
it anytime I cook a lobster before I put
it in the water I remove from the claws
so that it can try to bite me as it's
one last act of survival that is like
really sadistic at least give it a
chance to fight back
so I take off the rubber bands and then
it they pop open the pop and then it can
try to bite me and and I have to then
triumph over of course I do
cuz I'm smarter than a lot of you give
him one like fighting chance it's just
it's it's my own weakens I would say
thank you thank you thank you oh by the
way was been a guest on stark oh she's
great what about my favorite shows
Oh so interval granted so she she has
autism and she was sort of very much
aware of she can sort of empathize with
how the animals were feeling and she
created this whole system of when they
go to slaughter that they would gently
be like so it wasn't stressful for them
or sort of anxiety provoking but they
would get like sort of guided through
this sort of they were kind of like
tunnels into the slaughterhouse in a way
that was so they couldn't see what was
happening in front of them and it was
like this really humane way to bring
them there without just you know
throwing them in and giving them all the
anxiety of stress that they're about
corralling them in them yeah yeah and so
I thought that was really humane and
what's the people in the vegetarian
movement that hate her for that because
she made it that much more humane to
kill an animal that the vegetarians
didn't want killed in the first place
yes yes so we can go deeper into that
but the answer is you don't need a brain
but you need I think a nervous system
okay cool mmm-hmm we got a lightning
round
Jackie lightning oh this is scary so we
just do quick like yes sound bites we're
gonna sound bites okay here we go Jackie
give it to me from San Pongo salon
Facebook how our memories physically
stored in the brain also can wean plant
fabricated memory
in some way yes there in Santa there and
now they're in the brain via long-term
potentiation which is a physical process
that connects neurons to each other or
makes them sort of what what fires
together wires together that's the
quickest hebbian synapse it's called
cool so the more they fire together the
more they will remain connected yes in
such a way that they form a memory yes
I've always been your Sancho on
Instagram what does it mean to focus on
something how does it work good one that
means attention its attention and what
it is is it there's part of you brain
called the dorsal lateral prefrontal
cortex that's actually too many
syllables EF LPC of anyway no DL FPC
anyway so you you can engage certain
parts your prefrontal cortex that filter
out extraneous information and your kind
of mental energy is is focused on a
particular bit of information part of
the focus is taking away things that
would distract yes
yes and that's what people have problems
with their attention is that they're too
easily distracted they're not good at at
focusing in because of the distraction
cool got it
what I'm sorry one more inning Jack
Perry eight on Instagram will a brain
transplant or full body transplant ever
become a reality that's what I want to
know because you have the the Lou
Gehrig's disease folks where there but
their body decays what is a and then you
have the Alzheimer's folks where their
brain goes away
yes and I'm thinking in the future you
get the brain of the alh person and put
it in the body of the outside human
there yeah if only we could reconnect
and Rigo of growth at all I don't think
we're that we're close to it okay so I'm
gonna have to say no but maybe in the
next like hundreds of years 200 years
maybe but if we can do a brain
transplant I'm really I highly doubt it
yeah I'm gonna say no that's a no
there's a lot of reasons why we'll get
into it later dr. Frankenstein did a
brain transplant
yeah Eva's got the app be normal that's
right on Star Trek to Spock's brain
remember that we can probably
replace a brain with silicon at some
point my children silicon-based brain
but I don't know about taking a
biological human brain and putting on
another box what do you mean silicon the
the you mean silicon the element on the
periodic table you mean a computer brain
computer brain yeah so the idea is if
you can replace one neuron with a
silicon chip that does exactly the same
function on and off and then another and
another another at some point in
principle you can replace the head yeah
and inside a body but would it dream for
this special neuroscience edition of
Startalk cosmic queries Heather as
always thanks for being such a friend of
Startalk and you're one of our Startalk
all-stars and always great to have you
back yeah we don't see enough of you so
we should do every episode on the brain
don't you think guys everything involves
the brain come on let's do it
Jacqui Hoffman great are we try to get
tickets to your Yiddish production
English subtitles the Fiddler on the
Roof particular with you playing you
enter that's got to be hilarious I like
to think so
with my brain this was exhausting and I
was a stupid one so you've been
listening to possibly even watching this
episode of star talk I've been your host
Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always I bid you to
keep looking up
[Music]